-While you're young,
you don't know anything, really,
whereas it is my responsibility
to only grant the wishes
I am sure are good for Rosas.
♪♪
-So most of these wishes
will never be granted?
-Yet I still protect them
like all the others.
-Can't you just
give them back instead?
-Excuse me?
-The wishes
you're not going to grant.
You could just give them back.
Then -- I don't know.
The people can try
to pursue them themselves?
-We're back with Ariana DeBose,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a clip from "Wish."
It's a new Disney movie.
-Yeah, it is.
Celebrating 100 years of Disney.
-100 years. So, this cannot
come soon enough for me.
I mean that sincerely.
-Yeah?
-Because my boys,
the two older ones,
they're old enough
to go to movies now.
Bringing them to the movies is
my favorite thing in the world.
And not all kids movies
are good.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I think this one is.
-I believe it is.
I mean, again, it is obviously
in the safe hands of Disney.
And so what was your mom's
reaction when you told her
you were going to be
in a Disney movie?
-Oh, she --
I believe it went like this.
"You're doing what?
Wow! That's big!"
-Oh, wow.
-I was like,
"Yeah, it's cool, Mom."
She's like, "No, it's cool.
But this is big.
That's like the House of Mouse."
-That's very --
I like when your parents
outside of show business
want to let you know
how big something is.
-Oh, yeah.
It was a great moment.
We've had many great moments.
-So, tell us a little bit about
your character and the film.
Do not spoil anything
because I'm going to see it.
-I promise I will not.
-Okay. Thank you.
-But I do voice
the character of Asha.
-Great.
-And she's so beautiful.
Beautiful brown skin,
braids, and freckles.
Come on, now.
-Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Um, and...
And she lives in
the magical kingdom of Rosas.
And she is so
community-oriented.
She literally
just loves this space
where she believes
wishes can come true.
And she has this encounter
with King Magnifico
and discovers that things
are not all that they seem.
And she makes a powerful wish
and kind of accidentally
calls down the Wishing Star.
And they go on this
really cool journey
of trying to save their --
the community
and make life and the place
that they live better,
which I think
is kind of indicative
of the world we live in today.
-That's very nice.
It's very nice,
but it's a solid message
for the kids and the adults
who are with the kids.
You got to sing one of the songs
at Disneyland.
-I did. I did.
So "This Wish" is what I think
is kind of, like, the mother
of all "I want" songs.
Like, the Disney "I want" songs.
You know, like "Go the Distance"
from "Hercules,"
that sort of thing.
-Yeah.
-And I sang it recently
at Aurora's Castle
at Disneyland.
I'd never been.
So, cool, cool.
Everything's fine.
And it was -- it was so special
for many reasons,
but mostly because I looked out,
and the kids in the audience
were already singing the song.
-That's a trip.
-You know?
Like, that was --
It was one of those pinch-me
moments when you realize,
"Oh, this thing
that I said yes to
that I, you know,
had so much fun making..."
I put a lot of heart into it.
And to see that it's being
received from kids already
and that they're going to
sing this beautiful music
and learn from it
is kind of everything.
-That's so lovely.
And it just makes me...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-It also -- It also
just makes me dread
my kids butchering it
in the back seat of the car.
-That's -- See, but I like that.
-You like the butchering?
-I'm okay -- Well, come on.
How many songs --
I mean, "Let It Go."
♪ Let it go, let it go ♪
Like, it happens, but...
-Yeah.
-But it makes you
feel good inside.
Like, singing in the shower.
♪ So I'll make this wish ♪
Like, it's fine. Like,
sing to your heart's desire.
-That is still so much better
than them.
[ Laughter ]
Like, that's very cruel
that you're like,
"Bad like this."
I'm like, "Is that bad, though?"
'Cause I -- I feel like
I would listen to that.
-Oh, no.
-What were your favorites?
What was your favorites
growing up, your Disney movies?
-Oh, I had so many. I --
"Beauty and the Beast."
I was Belle for Halloween.
I was Snow White
for Halloween.
Granted, I'm giving
Evil Queen vibes today.
Anyone?
-Yeah, it's very good.
-And honestly,
she was very scary.
"Mulan."
-Mm-hmm.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
Like, come on. So graceful.
Everything.
"Hercules." The Muses.
Like, what?!
There are so many.
But wait. You were a Disney kid.
-I grew up with Disney. Yeah.
-So what are your favorites?
-From, like, a different era.
-That's okay.
-"Fantasia." No. Um...
[ Laughter ]
-Let's take it all the way back.
-These are the ones
that are, like, when I was --
This dates me, but it's always
the ones I saw in the theater.
So "Jungle Book."
"Sword in the Stone."
"Robin Hood" is one
I really like.
"The Rescuers"
was a big one for me.
-Oh, I love "The Rescuers"!
Medusa?!
-Yeah. Really good.
Really good villain.
-Really great villain.
Were you into "Tarzan"?
Because I was into "Tarzan."
-I did enjoy --
-I feel like I maybe --
You know what?
I'm gonna be honest.
I think I missed "Tarzan."
-What? Phil Collins?
"Trashin' the Camp"?
-Yeah.
-What?!
-I think, though,
there's this time in your life
between when you're a kid
and when you have them
that you're not like,
"I got to see
the new Disney movie."
[ Laughter ]
-You know,
I don't have children,
so I'm gonna say
that that's really fair.
-Yeah. But I will say --
You know what?
The one that I missed and then
my kids found is "Moana."
-So good.
-"Moana" now -- I can't --
And I've seen it a bunch
because it's their favorite.
You know what's interesting?
My oldest says this about
"Moana," and he's a boy.
He's like,
"'Moana' is my favorite
because the girl never
talks about true love."
And I'm like, "Look at them."
And I'm like --
That's really good that
it's, like, not -- like,
there's a female character
who's just, like, a hero
and it's not about her
trying to, like, find a dude.
-Find love.
And, you know, Asha and "Wish"
is inherently very much
like that, as well.
So, hopefully, your oldest
is going to enjoy it, too.
-Yeah.
-No, it's exciting when --
There are other stories to tell,
which I think is a good thing.
Like, I think what drew me
to "Wish" was the fact that,
like, you're watching
an unsuspecting girl
step into a leadership role.
It's not like
she was looking for it.
She just became it.
And she tries, she fails,
she tries again.
Like, those are beautiful things
that I think children
should learn.
-And, now, is it true
that your karaoke song
is a Disney song?
-Yes.
-What is it?
-"Colors of the Wind"
from "Pocahontas."
-Oh, wow.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, come on!
The Vanessa Williams
credit version is everything.
-Wow.
-She said...
♪ Can you paint with all
the colors of the wind? ♪
So good. Like...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I will be doing that
in the shower tomorrow!
-Yes!
-I cannot wait.
What a delight to have you here.
Thank you so much.
You guys, that's Ariana DeBose.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Wish" is in theaters nationwide
on November 22nd.
Stick around. We'll be right
back with Iman Vellani.